(dramatic strings playing)
This episode switches perspective
from our central trio
of Charles, Oliver, and Mabel
to Theo Dimas.
John pitched me the episode
as this silent episode
entirely from the point of view
of the deaf character.
One of the things we were
really adamant about was this
was not just a gimmick.
The person driving the episode
is a central,
emotional component
of the overall season.
I had the great privilege
of meeting James Caverly
who plays Theo early on in prep.
And it was great to meet him
because he asked me some great questions
and one of those questions was,
how will the deaf audience
know the difference
between Theo's storyline and
the storyline of the hearing characters.
It's great to inform the way
in which I wanted to shoot the episode.
We did a lot of
point-of-view shots
and we were really, really committed to
whatever Theo sees,
that's what we're shooting.
We're really grounding it in
his subjective point of view.
JOHN HOFFMAN: My favorite scene
is the crux of the episode
where Theo and Zoe
are on the rooftop.
CHERIEN DABIS: This is the moment that
we've been waiting for the entire series
where we finally get to find out
what happened 10 years ago.
I just felt stunned
by the level of performance
from Olivia and James.
Working with James was so much fun
in a way I've never experienced before.
We met on Zoom for some rehearsal
because I had realized that
I wouldn't know what my cues were
because his lines were also in sign.
Nathan and Olivia
learned ASL for this
and did such a remarkable job.
It's very challenging but Doug
coached me through the whole thing.
And of course James Caverly
was very supportive
of me trying to speak his language.
He's an extraordinary young actor
and his ability to do something
that was very difficult and very emotional
take after take after take,
I was so proud of him.
It was just one of those moments
where you get goosebumps
and remember
how much you love your job
because you're like
the first audience of something.
DABIS:
As an Arab-American woman,
I feel like so much of my career
has been about representing
the underrepresented,
and to be able to do that now
in the deaf community,
I just was so honored.
OLIVIA REIS: I think it
opens up a broader world
for what we expect
from television.
I think the bar is being raised
because we're seeing
that this works
really, really well.
♪ ♪